might disney actually release a predator
movie that's good
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
i would honestly hand on heart say that
the original predator with arnold
schwarzenegger is one of those rare
moments in cinema
it's a perfect movie
but could they actually be about to
release a movie that is a worthy
successor
i've seen the trailer for predator prey
and i gotta say i think it looks really
really good i think it looks really
promising i genuinely don't like
prequels i generally don't like them at
all but this one set around 1719 in the
comanche nation might actually be pretty
good i like how they've kind of gone low
tech with it but we'll talk about that
in a minute let's for a moment have a
think about the other predator movies
and why maybe they weren't successes to
the original
now first of all i'm going to start with
predator 2 with danny glover i actually
love that movie i think it's a great
film i think the problem with predator 2
is predator
it's always going to be compared to the
original and it's standalone predator 2
if ready to do was released first
i think it would have been seen as
a classic movie i think it would have
been seen as a great film on its own the
problem is it's always going to be
compared to the original and therefore
people have always been a bit about it i
do think that the actual casting of
danny glover maybe wasn't perfect but
obviously coming off lethal weapon
essentially he was the popular choice at
the time
i don't think it quite worked um but
other than that it's a great film
now after predator 2 we go into the avp
movies now alien versus predator was a
film i was actually very excited about
the
premise was actually really exciting and
they took elements from the
premise of avp and actually ended up
making it in the predators movie a few
years later um but we'll go back to that
in a sec um but the actual avp film and
then saying that there's this that that
whole history they're creating that
mythos they linked elements into the
actual aliens movie as well which i
quite liked um i thought would make a
great film and there are some cool bits
in it the bit where predator and alien
fight in the temple and thing and he's
swinging around by his tail and stuff
it's quite cool but overall
it's not a very good film
um it's a popcorn movie at best it's a
special effects film it doesn't really
add anything to the whole
story and to be honest it just didn't
quite work the game avp is much better
than the film ever was
if you do like the content by the way
guys please consider hitting the
subscribe button consider sharing the
video wherever the hell you like him
hitting that like don't hit the down
that doesn't help anybody
also
consider becoming a fully fleshed
sidetracker hit the join button all
these little things they really help me
to keep the channel going in and then
those few little pennies that basically
means the wife will let me keep doing it
now avp requiem
let's just leave it at that that film
was bloody awful it had no budget no st
i can't tell you who starred in it i saw
it not long ago and i still can't tell
you who starred in it i have no idea the
casting and casting is so important
films like this arnold schwarzenegger
original amazing um even danny glover in
the second one i would argue is you know
could be good casting but generally
speaking
um if generally speaking you cannot
remember any of the actors from a movie
it's not good casting going on from that
i actually think there was a good
predator movie the 2010 predators
with um toffee grace who actually from
that 70s show is an actor i actually
adore and actually particularly really
loved him in this casting because you
know he played that like weasley serial
killer all the way through you think
he's he's the cowardly thing he can't
understand why he's there and then it
turns out he's there because he's a
hunter in his own right he's a serial
killer i really like that little twist
in the movie um i really loved adrian
brody in this film he'd just come off an
oscar nomination actually an oscar win
he's a properly good actor um and he
actually filled this sort of action role
really really well i love that it did
add elements to the story it dragged
through this whole storyline and from
that should have been in avp really
about how the predators have set up a
reserve as such and that they would
capture people and monsters and things
like this from all over the known
universe and bring them to this nature
reserve if you like and hunt them there
i always really like that storyline from
avp i wish they
it was actually rumored that that was
supposed to be the storyline for the
original avp movie but they decided to
go another way last minute um i kind of
wish they'd merged those two two films
together i think it would have worked
much better
um but actually predators
was a good film it was pretty well
rounded it's not a bad sequel at all off
the back of that
they got to make the predator in 2018
now
this is a pure example of how to ruin a
movie
really really quickly the end sequence
where he gets the special predator suit
the
transformer thing that goes all over
all the way through thinking this isn't
a bad movie it's a popcorn movie it's
not you know it's just an action film um
i love thomas jane in it i love these
other actors that's something there's
something ensemble cast they're quite
cool the storyline gets a bit
towards the middle with the super
predator but that actually does lead
into a lot of what we know about the
predator them adds to the predator
because we know that they were
genetically modifying themselves and
that they would take the um best bits of
the creatures they hunted and try to
perfect themselves
um i liked that it added something to it
but
the end ruined the movie and
some of the casting wasn't great boyd
holbrook is a likable actor but you know
kind of forgettable i do happen to love
alicia olivia none though um i thought
she's one sorry see i think she's a
incredible beautiful woman and she's a
very good actress and she's actually
quite good in this role even though they
did fall into the trap of she runs
around screams a lot and then all of a
sudden becomes very good weapons
randomly halfway through the film just
suddenly
really good at guns i never really
understood that i hate it when they do
their movies um you know have some
character development people but
generally speaking it's not a terrible
popcorn action movie
until the end which makes you want to go
i've just wasted two hours of my life
kill me now predator prey which is
called predator schools for a long time
during development
is going to be released straight on to
disney plus and hulu in the united
states
that concerns me because i think if you
have a big project like this get on the
cinemas but disney plus have shown in
the last year really that even when
they've got a project that is going to
be released the cinemas they almost then
immediately released on disney plus they
are really pushing disney plus and
they're using their own content as they
should really to push disney plus as
much as possible they want it to be the
number one streaming service and in all
honesty it will be very very soon but
what do we think about the movie well i
put a survey on the channel um a few
days ago and the results are actually
pretty much 50 50. a lot of people said
yeah of course we could have a great
predator movie why not such a good
character other people said well the
trailer looks okay maybe yeah it looks
okay good enough other people back half
again they said no they can't make a
good predator movie evidence shows that
they can't and actually the trailer
looks awful but one comment i did find
quite interesting said well the person
they've cast is the main lead amber mid
thunder is a comanche which actually her
heritage is the comanche nation
she
is a really really like collector but
she is a little girl
now he said well look on schwarzenegger
big muscles and he couldn't even fight
the predator how's this little girl
going to
well i kind of think that's the point
in the original movie the point was that
arnold schwarzenegger's big powerful
bloke and his muscles didn't matter the
predator is bigger stronger
the only way to defeat him is with
smarts now in the actual trailer she
says
the predator knows how to hunt but i
know how to survive
and that is the point of the movie that
kind of the point of the predator
franchise in itself that our muscles our
weapons don't matter
it is
how wily you are how clever you are and
using brain over brawn now in that case
it really doesn't matter if you're a
little girl or a six foot arnold
schwarzenegger your muscles are
irrelevant so
even though
when i first heard about this project i
had exactly the same thoughts as as that
subscriber and other people who have
mentioned this film does look a little
silly how are people with axes really
going to take on the predator you have
to remember what the predator is
he doesn't want to use his laser weapons
unless he feels it's fair
he will
let pregnant women live he will do
things because he has a twisted sense of
honor it's all about the hunt we see
from the trailer that he uses a lot of
hand-to-hand combat when he is fighting
groups of comanche and
early settlers the other thing is the
predator will not just slaughter this
character straight away this little girl
he won't see her as a threat now she may
use that at her advantage
also we do see a part of her using the
mud and things like this so she's
obviously a very clever character i
actually would love to see if they do
this right
how this girl fights back against the
predator and survives
we see very early on in the trailer that
she's a girl with attitude that nobody
believes she can do anything and but she
does it anyway and for me that is the
epitome of bravery because bravery is
not about
you know doing something and not being
scared it's about being scared and doing
it anyway and hopefully for me that will
be the lesson from this movie
also
have a look at the trailer i'll put a
link in the description it looks like
it's been beautifully made and if they
keep this film
this side is silly and don't go too far
with it and keep it subtle this could be
a great great movie and i'm really
really looking forward to seeing it so
please get in the comments tell me
exactly what you think is this something
you are looking forward to is it
something that you weren't looking
forward to but actually considering my
comments you might give it a chance
hope so
get in the comments down tell me exactly
what you think also please like
subscribe hit the bell notification and
it really helps the channel out also if
you have enjoyed the content please
consider becoming a fully fledged side
tracker as always guys please stay safe
and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you